tom is so kind enough to join us the
great coach from Michigan State his team
22 and 9 beat Ohio State next game
either hi Oh State and Purdue Friday in
the Big Ten Tournament coach thanks for
joining us what have you been told about
the coronavirus well you know Dan I just
listened to what you said and I thought
you did it in a very professional and
good way in a human way yeah you know I
just met with my team to talk about you
know how we're right now still going I
don't know what will happen
hours to come but you know how we it's
just immediate family and just all the
things and I I'm starting to agree with
you you know I I don't know what is best
I'm leaving it to the experts I've we've
gone through a lot this year a lot of
different things that have happened and
it this is a whole nother beast that I
sure don't know I'm not an expert on and
I I'm just kind of waiting and seeing
like everybody else what if the Big Ten
ask you your opinion well what have been
a couple days ago if I was to be honest
with you where I would have said hey
let's play the games and and now I'm
looking at it and saying you know it
sure is starting to lean towards maybe
the best of things were postponed or
canceled but again I you know the
problem for me Dan is you know I hate
the social media and the social media
goes crazy on things and half you hear
C's is never true so I just got to look
at the experts in the health field and
whatever they tell us sounds like a
canned answer but that's kind of the
area that I would I would lean towards
what are you going to tell your kids you
know I want to tell him I just told them
I said listen we've dealt with adversity
of a suicide we dealt with the adversity
of losing our second best player for the
year we've dealt with one of our guys
Xavier Coleman's wife had a baby a day
after Marilyn
it's been one of those years where we
had a deal with some tragedy and some
joy but always distractions of some kind
and we've got to approach this the same
way if they tell us we're playing we
gonna we got to play and we got to try
to focus in on the task at hand and have
to tell us or not and we deal with that
what about playing in front of an empty
arena you know remind me of my division
two days I probably am a few Division
one coaches that has that experience but
I don't know you know somebody brought
it up to us we scrimmaged Gonzaga this
year in Denver kind of met there and and
we did it kind of in an empty arena and
I mean it is different but once the game
gets started it's like everything else
once the game gets started it's about
the game you know and but at this
magnitude I don't know how that'll feel
but if that's the best way to do it the
safest way to do it I'm all-in
yeah but we might hear some things from
you now you know like I said I've been
at Division two coats for one year I've
been a high school coach for one but hey
what you see is what you get you know
nobody there's no surprises it's whether
you want to carry those things on TV is
the key yeah I also wonder if we would
postpone this you know there there are
schools trying to qualify for the NCAA
tournament their schools trying to
improve their seating here but you know
the Ivy League just canceled theirs and
said Yale you go forward and you know
good luck you know could we get to the
point where you just say the regular
season champ is going to be representing
the big ten and then these games you're
not going to have games where you can go
okay that's going to help you qualify
for the tournament or improve your
seating it's possible you know I think
right now for the most part you know
most of the the most of the bigger
schools I mean I think we know who the
five six eight nine schools
gonna be I think where it's a problem as
those schools as Ivy League's that their
tournament champ is the only one that
gets in you know the one bid leagues and
whether they could do that I don't know
I think they could I still think you
could come up with a with a selection
show and everything but it's is it a
week from now is it going to be any
different I guess that's that's what I
have no clue
yeah and that's where I just think you
know applying caution to this and trying
to figure out what what is really best
for everybody involved and not just this
sport but all of this sports because
it's a gathering
it's a celebration we're very fortunate
in this country to have these
opportunities but I also think that this
is such a bigger picture here and if you
postpone the tournament I hope they
don't cancel it but if you poke like I
all I would want is a two-week period
here coach where we can just say okay
how big is this how bad is this how
concern just pushing it back to me would
would probably make the most sense a
band for a guy that sometimes I listen
to you because I do what you sure I do
listen to you every now and then more
and more now and then believe it or not
and if I was that great respect for you
I think I think a lot of times you kind
of find ways to joke with me and this
and that the serious side of you I think
is right on the money you know I I think
the biggest thing is it's all happened
so fast and then when it gets into
social media how do we know what's right
and wrong we've got to let the
professionals figure that out give them
a little bit of time so they're not
under these deadlines of the playing
game Matt Nolan do you do this do you do
that don't worry about any of those
things do what's best for our society
and I think that's what you're saying
and I think he'll I'd vote for you for
president on that statement well full
disclosure coach Kay was busy so that's
why we called you freaky things that
happen you got to get back to normality
yeah Patrick just did it yeah and
Calipari was busy Bay Hunt
I'm was busy to Michigan yeah bit of
people and we don't have to worry about
it but I do appreciate you and I
appreciate you know even talking about I
wish I I wish I was an expert in and I
think I'm an expert on a lot of things
I'm probably an expert on a few but this
is one I have no expertise on coach good
luck against either Ohio State or Purdue
on Friday we appreciate your time as
always thanks Dan that's Michigan State
head coach Tom Izzo